مجموعه كبيره
هم لا يريدون ان يقولوا الحقيقه انظروا
لما يحدث في وسائل الاعلام التي لا تريد
ان تقول الحقيقه وما يحدث ايضا
بيتحدثون عام يحدث لهم لكن
هؤلاء الاشخاص
يزدادون ثراء خصومنا
بذل كل ما يستطيعون
لسحق ارادتنا لكنهم اخفقوا في ذلك بل انهم
جعلونا اقوياء في عام 2024 ستكون المعركه
النهائيه سنعود الى البيت الابيض
وحقبتهم سوف تنتهي والولايات المتحده
ستكون مره اخرى دوله حره
[تصفيق]
عداءنا
يريدون ان يوقفوننا لانهم يعلمون اننا نحن
فقط من نستطيع ان نوقفهم لم يكن هناك اي
حركه شعبيه كهذه في تاريخ هذا البلد
لنعيد الى امريكا عظمتها من جديد اقول لكم
هذا لم يحدث في تاريخ
هذه البلاد على الاطلاق
وقلت لكم
وقلت لي قال
بشان هذه المنطقه التي نرغب في النص الى
قلبها لنقترب من نسبه مئه بالمئه ولكن
استخدام السلطه موجود في كافه مستويات
الحكومه هناك فساد مستشري في كل مكان هذا
يحدث امام اعيننا لكنها سوف نفوز ان
استخدام نظام
بايدن
لاجهزه انفاذ القانون
يرقى لما قام به
الاسترلينيون في السابق ويبدو ان هذا بدا
منذ بدايه
الشيوعيه
ونحن نبدو وكاننا جمهوريه من جمهوريات
العالم الثالث جمهوريه الموز مع التزويري
الانتخابات اضحينا جمهوريه الموز
ان يجب ان تتحقق ليس لي ولكن للجميع نحن
سوف ندافع عن ذلك عندما
تنتهي في هذه الانتخابات ساكون رئيس
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
وسوف تكونون فخورين والمجرمون
وسوف يهزمون
ويعيشون في
كان في اجواء من العار منذ البدايه كانت
مطارده وكذلك تحقيق مزيف الواحد تلو الاخر
وبلادنا لم تعد تتحدث عما تقوم به الصين
التي تنفق الاموال وتسيطر على الحكومات في
ارجاء العالم
الاشخاص لا يريدون ان يتحدثوا عن عظمه
بلادنا ما يريدون هو
التحقيق بشان الجميع ونشكر ايضا
الاعضاء الجمهوريين في الكونجرس الذين
يعملون دون هويدا مثل جيم جوردن وجيمس
وهؤلاء هم النجومي هم رجال عظام
يواجهون المخاطر وهم يقومون بشيء لم نشهده
في واشنطن منذ 25 عاما اشكرهما واشكر من
يتعاون معهم هؤلاء
يواجهون ما تعرض له من تحقيق في جميع
جوانب حياه الماليه والاجتماعيه وغيرها
حتى المحكمه العليا في الولايات المتحده
مناحتهم
الشهادات الضرائب الخاصه بهذا لم يحدث من
قبل حصلوا على كل ما يريدون بشاني المحكمه
العليا سلمته الى الادعاء العام
ولم يتم تعيين الا ثلاثه من قضاه المحكمه
العليا من قبلنا ومنحوهم كل ما يريدون
وقد اصدروا حكما بان هذا الامر لا يمكن ان
يطال رئيس وانما هذا ينطبق على ترامب ايضا
نحن ناس خاصون ليس هناك من يشبهنا هؤلاء
هم الافضل انظروا اليهم هم موجودون هنا
وتعلمون انهم حققوا هذه الاموال بالطريقه
القديم
انتم تعرفون هؤلاء واصدقائي من كارولينا
الشماليه
الذين هم من اجمل ما يكون او لا اشخاص
رائعون يسافرون كثيرا اعتقد انه الرقم هو
93 نحن نسمن فرانكو جون
101 والمحكمه العليا تشعر بالخوف على غرار
بعض الجمهوريين للتحرك ضد ما يحدث
والمحكمه العليا لم يكن لديها الشجاعه
لتصحيح الخطا الذي وقع في عام 2020 اذا
شهدت الضرائب كان دائما ينظر اليها على
انها مقدسه وطبعا هذه الوثائق كانت مقدسه
ولكن الان
المحامون يمثلون امام المحاكم ايزن وهم
يتعاملون مع المحامين وكانهم مجرمون
هو كانوا يحظون بالاحترام
وما كان يمكن ان يتم ملاحقتهم ولكن ذلك
يحدث الان هذا امر غريب يحدث اذان وحتى
الاساتذه القانون يوجهنا هذه
المصاعب احد عشر مليون صفحه من الوثائق تم
تصرحها ولم يحصل من خلالها على اي شيء
وطبعا لدي اوراقي الخاصه بالضرائب ربما
هذا يجعلني اكثر الاشخاص
براءه في تاريخ الولايات المتحده قال لي
احد الاصدقاء ان او في الصفحه الثالثه
امسكوا
سلمناهم احد عشر مليون وثيقه الى مجموعات
مختلفه بما فيها الكونجرس الاسلحه الجديده
التي يتم استخدامها من قبل
الديمقراطيين وهناك تزويل للانتخابات ايضا
باضافه الى
التشويه السمعه هذا ما يحدث لها هل يمكن
شرح ذلك الدعم اشرح لي هذا الامر ايها
العضو الكونغرس عليك ان تشرح لي هذا الامر
ولكن هم يحصلون على الكثير من الدعايه لان
هذه القضيه يتم النظر فيها من خلال وسائل
الاعلام الناس مجرد هره
هذه معامله غير منصفه لكن ذلك يحدث من قبل
وزاره العداله وكذلك مكتب المدعي العام
وفي جميع ارجاء البلاد هم يستخدمون
المكاتب المحليه في نيويورك واتلانتا
وتشيكاغو
وهم يجعلوا الحياه بئيسه ويحطمون الاسر
والاصدقاء على الرغم من انهم يدركون ان
هؤلاء ابرياء وفي الكثير من الحالات هم
وطنيون لم يرتكبوا اي جرم على الاطلاق
حتى دان لا اعتقد انهم لاحقوه ولكن هناك
بعض
الاعضاء الكونجرس الذين لا يمكن ان تتم
لحقتهم لانهم نظيفون اكبر من اي شيء اخر
هم يقومون بالتحقيق مع اشخاص سعيدان هم
سوف يخسرون
هذه السباق وهذه هي انتخاباتهم يحققون
ويجرون هذه التحقيقات لانهم سيكون من صعب
عليهم تعبئه صناديق الاقتراع بطاقات
التصويت وتم العثور على خمسه ملايين حاله
التزوير لكن المحاكم غدت الطرف عن ذلك
والمدعي العام في نيويورك باوامر من وزاره
العدل في
واشنطن تحقق معي
بشاني ليس جريمه او جنح او قضيه
طبعا لما يعجبني على الاطلاق هذا النوع من
المعامله
الفظيعه انا لن اكون شخص
لدينا هنا
سيده اولى عظيمه
يحبها الشاب حقا وقد انجزت عملا رائعا
وليس لديهم ايت ادله ولكنهم يواصلون
يتمادون في ما يقومون به وقد تم زرع
عملاء من بينهم ماتلو كولانجو وهو من كبار
المسؤولين في وزاره العدل تم نقله الى
مكتب الادعاء الان في نيويورك حتى يتم
استخدام المكتب المحلي اذا
الواحد كبار المسؤولين
تحت مسؤوليه المدعي العام تم ارساله الى
نيويورك ليعمل في مكتب من هات من اجل
الملاحقه وكذلك العمل على التخلص من ترامب
لان ارقام ترامب مرتفعه جدا وهم لا يعجبهم
ذلك
فزنا في 2016
وفزنا باعداد اكبر في عام 2020 لكن
الانتخابات كانت مزوره حصلت على اكبر عدد
من الاصوات اكثر من اي رئيس اخر في تاريخ
هذه البلاد حصلنا على الاصوات في اكبر عدد
من المقاطعات في تاريخ بلادنا اكبر بكثير
مما حصل عليه بايدن لكنهم قالوا اننا
خسرنا الانتخابات اذا علينا ان نكتسح
الامر الان حتى ننتصر وقد سمعنا الكثير من
المتحدثين
قل لي ما علينا القيام به يوم الثلاثاء
يمكن التصويت ولكن الات التصويت يمكن ان
تكون غير صالحه هذا ما قاموا به
والجمهوريون يفضلون التصويت يوم الثلاثاء
هم يعلمون ان لا التصويت ليس صالحه
وبالتالي يفضلون الانتظار في طوابير
الناخبين للتصويت
هم يسرقون ويكذبون وهذا ما هم بارعون فيه
والسمحوا لاشخاص بدون بطاقات هويه
بالتصويت فكروا في الامر
88% من الديمقراطي يريدون تصويت ببطاقه
الهويه انهم يرغبون في تزوير الانتخابات
والجمهوريين لا يمكن ان يقبلوا هذا الامر
بعد عليهم ان يتبنوا موقفا صارم
الجمهوريون في واشنطن مثل ميتشو ماكانو من
اسوا ما يمكن ان يكون هناك من سياسيين
عليهم ان يكونوا اقوياء ومثل ماركوري
التي يمكن ان تترشح
لمنصب مجلس الشيوخ ومعنى انظروا الى
فهو قد اثبت موقفا
وقلت انه ربما قد ذهب الى ابعد ما
يجب ان يذهب اليه ولكن ثم قلت لا هذا صحيح
وقد تم استخدامه ايضا كوسيله عامان من
الجحيم لكنه اتضح بانه الرجل شجاع ووطني
الشجاع ونتعلم الكثير عن الاشخاص وبالتالي
هو استاذه امتحان وحصل على العلامه كامله
في هذا الامتحان
وطبعا
سبب بانه ليس كما تهمه خصومه بانه
كاذب
وطبعا هذا ادى الى وجود عدد كبير من
المؤيدين ونحن نحترم الاشخاص الذين
يستحقون هذا الاحترام مثل المحامين في
نيويورك نظروا الى كافه الوثائق الوثائق
التي سلمت من بينها القضايا السابقه التي
تم